great
another samsung tablet
ouch
wait wait joanna don't toss me aside
this time i swear i am the galaxy tab
that's better than the ipad
right that's what they all say that's
what i heard from the galaxy tab 8.9 the
galaxy tab 10.1 the galaxy note oh
really i have a crazy high resolution
super amoled screen a really thin and
light design a fingerprint sensor and
new software features that everyone
wishes the ipad had oh and i come in two
sizes the 10.5 inch version starts at
499
and the 8.4 inch version starts at 399.
you know what this crazy talking tablet
doesn't actually sound so crazy
after who knows how many tablets samsung
seems to have finally gotten its act
together with the tab s but can this
tablet really beat the reigning ipad
i'll be the judge of that
samsung has pulled a honey i blew up the
smartphone the tab s looks and feels
like a huge galaxy s5 with the same
plastic dimpled back and metallic frame
around the screen
it's also noticeably thinner and lighter
than the ipad but that's because it's
still made out of plastic which means it
doesn't quite feel as substantial as the
ipad's aluminum build but the tabas has
something the ipad doesn't a fingerprint
sensor the only problem is it doesn't
always work and requires a lot of
precision wait 25 seconds are you
kidding me where i can say the tab s
outshines the ipad is with its crazy
2560 by 1600 resolution super amoled
display the resolution is higher than
the ipads and the screen is gorgeous
everything is crisp and it even
automatically adjusts the contrast and
brightness based on what app you're
looking at it doesn't take a big hit on
battery life either the big tab lasted
11 hours and the small 10 hours just as
long as the ipads and the tab s's screen
looks a lot better outdoors which is a
problem i've always had with the ipad
the screen causes a lot less glare and
direct sunlight when it comes to
software the tab s has a key feature
that so many want me included to come to
the ipad the ability to put two apps
side by side it also has support from
multiple user accounts and a new feature
called sidesync that allows galaxy s5
owners to view their phone on the tablet
and make calls from it unfortunately for
now the tab s only pairs with the galaxy
s5 it's time we have to talk about your
software and i mean this in the nicest
way possible but it's a mess your custom
skins don't add any value and what are
these promotional widgets doing
everywhere lg and htc have streamlined
their interfaces isn't it time you just
cleaned yourself up
okay maybe that was a bit harsh but you
know what tabas i like you in fact i
think you're the best tablet samsung has
ever made
these tablets have really nice screens
really thin and light designs and some
cool software tricks i still prefer the
ipad for its cleaner and more simple
software interface but if you're looking
for an android tablet these are a really
good alternative especially for the
price
have i really been talking to tablets oh
yes you have i'm losing my mind